[Music]
i grew up on a bee farm in missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock we had to raise a lot of our
own feed to stay in business
economically
and we raised corn and soy beans and hay
and you grind this material up into a
flower
you make pellets you add vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals to this
pellet
and you feed those calves for about six
to nine months before you ship them off
to market
maybe to be butchered maybe to other
feeders and you always say back the very
best ones for yourself and you knock
them in the head and eat them
it's a real simple cycle on the farm the
thing that fascinated me as a teenager
was that as a family we lived out of the
same fields we kept back five rows of
corn for ourself
we had a garden at the end of the field
where we grew our peas and beans and
squash and tomatoes
and we wanted to live to be a hundred
with no aches and pains yet we didn't
give ourselves the same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals
that we gave the livestock this whole
concept really fascinated me and i went
on to ag school
at the university of missouri and there
i learned about
chemistry soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre
i learned about ag economics but i
really didn't get an answer to my basic
question
why did we give these calves vitamins
minerals and trace minerals and not
ourselves until i became a freshman
veterinary student
at the university of missouri and there
i learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds
bottom line is because we don't have
health insurance for them
and of course if we were to use a human
health care type of
system for livestock it'd be sticker
shock for you
your your hamburger cost would be 275 a
pound
boneless skinless chicken breasts would
be four hundred and fifty dollars a
pound
and a dozen eggs be fifty dollars for a
dozen eggs
so we learned that we could keep the
price of animal products such as meat
and dairy
and poultry and eggs down to where the
average american could afford them
simply by reducing or eliminating health
care costs
we do this in animals by preventing and
curing diseases with nutritional
formulas
that whole concept fascinated me all
through veterinary school
and while the other vet students were
playing bridge and throwing harshes
during breaks i spent a lot of my time
in the library
studying more nutrition after graduating
vet school i went to africa for two
years and got to work with marlon
perkins from the old mutual omaha wow
kingdom days
that was kind of a kick i got to play
frank buck and trudge all over
central and south africa using the
tranquilizer gun and moving elephants
and rhino all over the continent of
africa and
europe the united states and after two
years
marlin sent me a telegram and invited me
back to the states to work on a big
project
he'd actually gotten a and a half
million dollar grant from the national
institutes of health
and this was to study pollution the
environment and ecology this is more
than 35 years ago
and my job as the wildlife veterinarian
on the project
to do autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the big zoos around
the united states
and i was supposed to identify a species
of animals that were ultra sensitive to
pollution
and we're going to use that animal much
like the old coal miners used to use
canaries remember how that story goes
they
take the canaries down into the mine and
if methane gas or carbon monoxide
were to leak into the mine the canaries
were more sensitive than men and they
would drop off the perch and die long
before the men were in
danger of suffocating or blowing up well
to make a long story short after some
12-plus years working directly with
perkins
at the st louis zoo the brookfield zoo
in chicago the national zoo and dc
la zoo and many other large zoos around
the united states i had done some 17
500 autopsies on over 454 species of
animals
plus 3 000 human beings for a comparison
what i learned was that every animal and
every human being who dies of natural
causes
dies of a nutritional deficiency disease
and i got all excited about nutrition
again
and i wrote 75 scientific papers during
medical journals and veterinary journals
international pathology journals
i wrote some fifteen chapters for eight
multi-author textbooks
i wrote a textbook of my own it was a
thousand pages and two thousand
illustrations
and through the news releases of the
large universities i worked with i was
on 2020 with
hugh downs and geraldo before he got his
nose broke for the first time
and through the news releases again
through the universities i was in some
1700 newspapers around the world through
the upi and ap news wire service
and with all this public exposure with
all the scientific exposure
i couldn't get people who are in a
position of authority either in medical
research
or in government to get too excited
about preventing and curing diseases
in human beings with nutrition like we
did in animals so i got
frustrated enough i went back to school
in portland oregon became a physician
and i practiced there for 12 years as a
general family practitioner
and i used everything that i had learned
in veterinary nutrition in my human
patients
and of course this was no surprise to me
that the concept works just as well in
people
as it does in animals
there are 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids
and 3 essential fatty acids and they're
called essential nutrients for two
reasons number one
our bodies cannot manufacture them we
must consume these essential nutrients
every day
either as food or as a supplement number
two
if any one of these 90 essential
nutrients is missing for a couple of
weeks couple months
couple years you get on the average 10
deficiency diseases
10 deficiency diseases times 90
essential nutrients that's
900 diseases that are preventable with
proper supplementation
and the nice thing about this concept is
if you have any of these 900 deficiency
diseases
and you supplement properly you have
every honest expectation
of getting some significant benefit many
people will get 100 better
then we haven't had to think about this
over the years as
since human beings have been on earth
simply because our food plants our
grains vegetables fruits and nuts
have been able to manufacture the
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids
and this whole concept was very
interesting to researchers back in the
30s and 40s they believed
that you could get everything you needed
from your four food groups because
plants did manufacture vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids that's where
that whole malignant dumb belief came
from
that you could get everything you needed
from your four food groups and of course
that little sentence has killed more
americans
than all the foreign enemies put
together in the 220 years we've been a
nation
now you notice i didn't talk about
minerals minerals are a different
concept
minerals cannot be manufactured by
plants as we've already said
and as a result you have to consciously
supplement with minerals you can get
some vitamins you can get some
vitamin a and beta-carotene and vitamin
c and vitamin e from your grains
vegetables fruits and nuts
but you cannot get minerals you cannot
guarantee you're going to get minerals
so you must
supplement with minerals for this reason
how important are minerals well
they're used as cofactors for vitamins
you cannot use vitamins without mineral
cofactors
you cannot use enzymes you cannot use
hormones you cannot use dna
rna chromosomes you cannot even use
oxygen without mineral cofactors
that's how important they are secondly
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around across the earth
minerals occur in veins like chocolate
ripple ice cream
and you know chocolate ripple ice cream
is 99 vanilla it's just one percent
chocolate and here's our problem plants
cannot manufacture minerals
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
they make up two-thirds of the 90
essential nutrients
60 minerals out of 90 nutrients two
thirds of the ninety essential nutrients
are minerals that's how important they
are
now one of the things that cause
problems in addition to plants being
able to
not being able to manufacture minerals
and minerals not occurring in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
is that we've used a simple fertilizer
for the last hundred years in the united
states
called npk nitrogen phosphorus potassium
and a simple fertilizer gave the farmers
the maximum yield in terms
of tons and bushels per acre nobody gave
a farmer any kind of tax break or cash
incentive
to make sure that you and i got all 60
essential minerals that's our own
responsibility
farmers grew tons and bushels now one of
the things i want you to pick up
one of the things i want you to get is a
copy of u.s senate document 264.
u.s senate document 264 says that
there's no longer any nutritional
minerals left in our farm and range
soils
and as a result the grain specialist
fruits and nuts that are grown there are
minerally deficient
and as a result the animals and people
who eat these merely deficient
grains vegetables fruits and nuts get
mineral deficiency diseases and the only
way to prevent and cure them
is with mineral supplementation now to
me the scary thing about u.s senate
document 264
is that it was written and published in
1936 and at that time we began to put
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
into animal feeds to make up the
difference and
of course since that time we've been
able to prevent and cure all kinds of
diseases and animals with these
nutritional formulas
unfortunately for human beings we got
wonder drugs in 1936 we got sulfa drugs
in 36
we had penicillin in 38 and we got
cortisone and 42
and it was very easy for the medical
profession to
calm the american public into believing
they would find a wonder drug
to fix everything if we just gave them
enough money for research and if we
faithfully watched dr marcus welby md
that they would find a wonder drug to
fix everything well you don't believe
that anymore
that's why you're that's why you're here
because you don't believe this anymore
you cannot get everything you need from
your four food groups and you must
and you must supplement with your
vitamins and your minerals
there are five early warning symptoms
that even a five-year-old can recognize
when you have mineral deficiencies that
are
dangerous and life-threatening number
one is white gray and silver hair
white grain silver hair indicates a
copper deficiency because copper is
required to manufacture hair pigment
doesn't matter if your hair color if
your original hair color
is blonde or red or brown or black
copper is required as a co-factor to
manufacture this hair color so if you
have white gray or silver hair
you actually have a copper deficiency
now if this was just a cosmetic problem
it'd be no worry but there are more
sinister things going on when you have a
copper deficiency
copper is also required as a cofactor to
manufacture
the elastic fibers in your body
including the elastic fibers and veins
and arteries
when you get a breakdown of the elastic
fibers and veins you get spider veins
and varicose veins
which can result in certainly discomfort
but also
you get a breakdown of the elastic
fibers and veins you begin to get
a twisting and turning of the veins so
you're at high risk of getting a
thrombosis
or a blood clot which can go to your
lungs cause pulmonary embolism
or stroke then if you get a breakdown of
the elastic fibers in your arteries you
get a balloon in that area of weakened
wall
of the weakened arterial wall and this
is called an aneurysm and if it's in a
strategic location like in your head
or a coronary artery and it ruptures you
will bleed to death in seconds
or you can get a stroke from that type
of of bleeding in the skull
this is due to a copper deficiency now
the nice thing about this is if you
supplement with colloidal
and chelated copper the hair color will
begin to come back and it always comes
back first
at the nape of the neck comes back over
the top of the head then the
sides of the head you're going to look
like a pinto pony for a couple of
months while this regrowth of hair color
is going to take place
but when you see this hair color coming
back on the outside you know that the
elastic fibers are healing on the inside
in your veins and your arteries
secondly there's the liver spots or age
spots in the back of your hands or
facing your neck
and these liver spots uh if you have
five of them on the outside you actually
have
millions of them in your brain your eyes
your thyroid gland your lungs your heart
your liver your kidneys your bone marrow
and these are actually rancid fat
they're called trans fatty acids
they're called seroid is a technical
name c-e-r-o-i-d
cyride lipofuxin these are trans fatty
acids they're
free radicals they increase your risk of
cancer and heart disease
many many hundreds of percent if you
actually have
a eyelid twitch if you have a toe cramp
foot cramp
leg cramp if you have spasms of the
large muscle groups in your back
this indicate indicates a calcium
deficiency if you have a calcium
deficiency
you don't want to wait until of course
you have something tragic happen like
compression fractures
are a fracture of your hip or your leg
which can be life threatening
you want to supplement with calcium in
the most
quick way you can do it and of course
you want to do this as colloidal and
chelated calcium so you can rebuild
those bones and
this is extremely important don't miss
these things you could be 15 years old
and have an eyelid twitch your body is
telling you that you have a calcium
deficiency
if you have low blood sugar narcolepsy
or hyperinsulinemia
if you have diabetes if you have adult
onset type 2 diabetes
this indicates that you have a chromium
and vanadium deficiency
and if you supplement with chelated and
colloidal chromium and vanadium
it'll take about four to six months for
your low blood sugar your narcolepsy and
your hyperinsulinemia to stabilize
and in a period of a couple of months
you should be able to significantly
reduce
the amount of either insulin or oral
medication you're taking for your animal
onset and type 2 diabetes
then the most common symptom of
mineral deficiency occurs in 95
of all americans this is a symptom
called pica and cribbing it's a
technical name for cravings and binge
eating habits
in 1975 the us department of agriculture
said
95 of all americans regardless of age
are minerally deficient
and the most universal symptom of this
mineral deficiency is pica and cripping
these are
our cravings and binge eating habits and
the snack food industry has convinced
people
when you have these cravings and you
have these binge eating habits
and behaviors is because you need their
chips and dips and candies and chocolate
and soft drinks
and so forth in fact your body is
screaming
for minerals and all you have to do is
supplement with minerals
and this binge eating habits go away now
farmers know about this
they see animals chewing on fences and
half doors in the barn these animals
will be chewing on
wire and nails and the paint off the
barn a good farmer or rancher will give
those animals some minerals
to save on veterinary bills to save the
animal's life and
to prevent having to rebuild the fence
little children
little toddlers will also get pike and
craving and i know you've seen them
eating dirt and sand and handfuls of
dirt out of the house plants
in the extreme they may even eat the
tootsie rolls out of the kitty litter
box
they might eat the lead paint or the
caulking from around the windows this is
because they're merely deficient
and they're craving things they're going
to stick a lot of things in their mouth
trying to identify what they need
pregnant women are legendary for having
pika and cribbing as the embryo develops
it steals minerals from the mother it
steals minerals from the mother
to develop and if she's not
supplementing with minerals faster than
the embryo
is taking them from her she's going to
develop pike and cribbing
she's going to want pickles and ice
cream usually at two o'clock in the
morning she's gonna want pickles and ice
cream
she's gonna want chocolate curly french
fries she may go out in a moonlit night
out in the backyard with a spoon and eat
clay
this is because the embryo is taking
minerals from her faster
than she is taking them in teenagers are
legendary
at having pike and cribbing adult
non-pregnant women and adult men also
get pike in cribbing
and this is because they're merely
deficient and again their bodies are
screaming for minerals
don't forget 95 of all americans are
minerally deficient
and only you can consciously take in
those 60 essential minerals remember
10 deficiency diseases times 60
essential minerals is 600 diseases
that are preventable with proper mineral
supplementation
and the way to do it is by using the
plant derived colloidal minerals
which are up to 98 available to you as
opposed to
inorganically bound minerals which are
ground-up rocks these are only three to
five percent available to an adult
and the best way for human beings and
animals to take in the way we're
designed to do it
is in the plant-derived colloidal farm
we are not designed to eat up
mineral supplements we are not designed
to consume minerals
as a ground-up rocks in any way shape or
form we're designed to get our minerals
by eating grains vegetables fruits and
nuts the way it's supposed to be in the
big scheme of things
is that our food plants our grains
vegetables fruits and nuts take minerals
out of the soil the inorganic minerals
out of the soil
convert them to colloidal minerals for
their own use and then we eat these
grains vegetables fruits and nuts and
that's how we're designed to get our
minerals
and unfortunately plants cannot
manufacture minerals
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
we've used a very simple fertilizer over
the years npk
nitrogen phosphorus potassium to make
sure we get the maximum yields in terms
of tons and bushels per acre
nobody gives a farmer any kind of tax
break to make sure we get all
60 essential minerals therefore it's
yours my responsibility to do that
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you
for more presentations and books that go
into greater detail
go to doc wallockmedia.com and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the fda
these products are not intended to
diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
the opinions expressed in this
informational program
are the express opinions of joel d
wallick bsdvmnd
are not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment
in all cases we recommend you contact
your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions